the Joe Rogan experience yeah he's
definitely rubbing his dick a he
tramples on TV just tweaking China
[ __ ] trade relations [ __ ] Jeffrey
Epstein [ __ ] all these [ __ ] oh we
can just weekend could you imagine
doesn't he knows Jeff right Jeff Epstein
apparently knew him look uh apparently
they got a falling out over our mansion
I was reading a story about it over like
when he sold him or no they were both
trying to buy some super exclusive
property that was like the crown jewel
mom Beach it was this six acre mansion
that overlooks the ocean it's on the
beach it's beautiful this is a hell of a
plantation for girls
well these yeah well it's also one of
those things where like if you're in a
part of these communities there's
certain properties that are iconic and
they own them it would elevate your
social status here Trump bought those
manchanda Schulman bubbly [ __ ] had like
a name to it the places off the charts
if you you see if you see it on TV like
you get a that's not it
what is this other those cans family
he's known to having a famous walking
stick I thought you were showing Epstein
intro it did Akane what was the house
Google the the house that they competed
about Trump and him competed over a
house made waterfalls well it's really
old I think 14 year olds in every room
it's like if someone was like a super
billionaire character
I don't know think of name some famous
man it was the Hearst Castle and Hearst
Castle for sale there you all be trying
to get it
Trump and Epstein's friendship
reportedly soured after they fought over
a forty 1 million dollar Palm Beach
mansion two weeks after the homes
auction cops received a tip about
underage women in Epstein's house say oh
[ __ ] that was that was candy land yeah
let's see if they have pictures of the
place that's like a Taj Mahal look at
that thing yeah that's it yeah thanks
gorgeous dude it's dope as [ __ ]
the images are insane that's it right
there click on that look at that place
so that you get it they're fighting over
who's got the biggest dick on
if you own that [ __ ] you bought
that place like you're king baller
everybody wants to have the party at
your house right I mean so I guess
there's just a few of these type of
mansions down in Palm Beach but there's
a lot of them I mean there's a you know
I don't know what the number is but
there's a good solid number of them I
mean against yeah that's [ __ ]
incredible it's sort of like like the
White House well it's sort of like those
houses in in Malibu like there's some
houses in Malibu you look at like
there's one crazy mansion overlooking
the sea and then another one next to it
like the I don't I don't live there
either right oh sure they weren't mostly
burnt to a crisp okay
it did sorry Point Dume era it's crazy
over it now is like just so many houses
charm on just charred yeah but those
houses that where the people do live
with that kind of of you I mean that's
those are super super valuable and in
Florida and West Palm Beach
apparently look at super super wealthy
yeah yeah under thirty-five million
dollars I mean Harvard throw a million
amazing Italian Renaissance tile mega
mansion in Palm Beach Florida if if you
buy that you're King [ __ ] you just swing
and dick all over come on in by the way
why did God make the dick size why why
is that to make you work harder really
that's really the reason have you just
if you had a giant hog you just waiting
around waiting for girls to come to you
I'm say but he can make dicks all the
same size now there'd be no competition
no no no can't make years the same size
either sorry not noses not eyebrows no
uniformity no eugenics okay yeah you got
to work harder get a little dick to
figure out how to get by in this world
like a you're God's brain and those big
dudes man they just don't have the
motivation to hardly ever get anything
done right they're just too busy
slinging dick that's you skirt around
them you pass them in the game take him
on the inside turn I didn't know that
that's what it is